[Music]
okay
they said i've been with my girlfriend
for over a year and i feel like i'm only
staying with her because i feel like if
i leave she'll kill herself but there's
no more love in this relationship just
arguments and problems
that's a lot um
ugh
i understand the feeling of like
not wanting to be the reason someone
kills themselves and wanting to save
everyone and i understand depression and
sadness because i've been there
and i get it but you can't put it on
someone else like that you know it's
just not fair to do
my little brother cried the night i left
for college
that has made me cry more than i care to
admit
if he watches this
i love you little bro
i feel like this person really has a
deep connection with his um with his
family
um
i wish i had that with my family i wish
i could tell him i could tell my dad
that i love him more
um
yeah i
yeah
yeah
my father has told me horrible things
and abused me yet he is the only man in
my life that i would do anything for
um wow
i've been lucky enough to not go through
anything like this but and i think it
man
i think it's a common thing to
like both feel like love and hatred for
people it happens a lot more than we
like to believe
and i think
what i would say to this person is just
trying to find the happiness
that you look for in him and other
people in your life within yourself and
try to grow from it as much as you can
it's hard to realize that your problems
are
this big compared to everyone else's
sometimes i know that everyone has
problems but
people are going through [ __ ] and that's
that's hard to cope with sometimes
this is really sad
i always tell my friends they have to
love themselves
but actually i don't love myself either
my thoughts is that that was really
authentic i was real most the time we
don't really love ourselves and if we
don't love ourselves we can't love
others and i think a part of whoever
wrote that wanting other people to love
themselves because they want to love
themselves so they tell their friends to
do it maybe if their friends could do it
then they could do it but it's my
thoughts on that one
i feel like i would need to elaborate
because whoever reads that they wouldn't
understand
because it's a complex
it's a complex secret it's something
that is built into our society there's a
lot of societal factors
in play in my secret that people just
don't understand because
they don't deal with it every day they
don't understand this person wrote i
have yet to be convinced either by
myself or by others that my life or my
passions have any value whatsoever
i mean the thing about your
your passions is like
at least for me that's kind of my reason
for
living and kind of like vibing
on the planet so
it also says here that
they're not convinced that their life
has value
um
just know that you're loved and
i had a friend that didn't
think that once and um
i wish they would have come to talk to
me
so
yeah
i was ripped and got pregnant i wish i
never got the abortion i mean to be
honest i kind of had a feeling that i
was going to get one like that
considering the school that i go to and
the culture that's here especially
with the um greek life and the
environment that's around that
i'm sorry that she regrets
having gotten that abortion and i'm
sorry that that happened to her it
shouldn't happen to anyone anywhere ever
period
i wish i could fake my death to see how
my friends would truly react it's a very
human feeling i feel like everyone
thinks about that
but uh
very real and i hope
they're around friends who
who do value their life
[Music]
um not really relieved i feel like even
after writing it's gonna stick with me
but um
the secret is
it's very dear to me nonetheless even if
it's positive or negative i feel like i
gotta keep it with me at all times yeah
it's devastating knowing that i will
never be a kid again
i'm scared of the question
you okay
because i'm not
i was once convicted of first degree
murder i don't tell people because i
don't think they will understand
one of my former sdsu professors would
buy alcohol for me and my underage
classmates they were also super
emotionally abusive towards us all low
last year i got blackout drunk and tried
to kill myself when people ask about the
scar on my neck i say i got it in a
knife
fight with the crazy [ __ ] which is true
but the crazy [ __ ] was me
all my best friends are bad [ __ ] i
think about kissing them sometimes but i
had a best friend i caught feelings for
freshman year and she ghosted me so i
don't want that to happen again
i wish people would love me the way i
love them i think i'm trans but i'm too
scared of the implications to actually
come out to anyone other than myself you
wrote this on canvas like i'll be your
friend i don't know who you are but just
know i accept you and you're amazing no
matter what and
it can be hard to come out but
it's the right thing to do and the
people who love you will always accept
you for who you are
all right so this one says i miss myself
i don't know where i am
it says i miss myself i don't know where
i am
i feel like that's really common in
college because we're on like a college
campus
and
it's so heartbreaking because i know
everyone's in the same place but like
they're also so distant especially with
like last year like copenh we just had a
suicide on this campus too and it's just
like so heart-wrenching it really breaks
my heart to hear stuff like that that's
so sad everyone feels alone and lost so
that's sad
and i've been there
so this person says
i have a lot of friends
but they have other friends and i only
have them so sometimes i feel alone when
they are distant with the other friends
because i don't have anybody else
i can relate to that [ __ ] sadly but it's
fine
uh like
i feel like i can low-key relate to that
if i'm gonna pull it back up again
because
um
yeah i would say that i had two like
have a lot of friends and then i i like
get jealous occasionally when i feel
that they have other friends too but
it's like
it's something that i'm personally
really insecure about but it's something
that i feel like i shouldn't be so i
push it back
and it's just kind of like
it's like a
negative feedback loop it's just like a
bunch of [ __ ] internally
i wish i had more time to enjoy my life
i feel like a robot sometimes
i can definitely relate to that i would
say take time to enjoy the little things
in life
like for me i try to like romanticize
school
i'll sit somewhere nice with a pretty
view read a book i'll get myself a cup
of coffee just the little things that
add up it just makes my day a little
better doesn't make me feel like i'm
forced to be here and i don't feel like
i'm just a student here like with
another red id or something
okay it says i have absolutely no idea
what i'm doing honestly i completely
relate to this this is my first year
here in grad school
as a literature major because i want to
be a professor
still don't know if i want to do that i
feel like there's a lot of expectations
from my family being asian
and a professor is not really
a thing that people look up to in my
culture i guess yeah i can relate to
that and all i can say is it eventually
works out and i know it's gonna work out
for me too
but i'm just
here along for the ride i don't really
know what's gonna happen
but um you're not alone yeah
i've never been on a date i have never
been in a relationship before i've never
held hands with someone and i've never
received flowers i feel so unlovable i
wish there were other ways for like them
to like look at options you know to feel
like you know
have you held fans with family you know
a little kid a nephew or anything like
that because those people you know if
you've got a nephew or a young child or
a niece i shouldn't be gender specific
you know someone young that like wants
to hold your hand they can love you
unconditionally like i'll be honest and
this isn't a secret that this wasn't
going to be something that i write but
like i've only been on one or two dates
with people and i don't have an
extremely high amount of romantic
relationships with a lot of people and
so like i faced some of these similar
challenges of being like how do i find
myself and view myself as someone who
can be loved in a romantic way or
anything like that there's a lot of ways
to experience and spread love and the
more that like you are willing to open
yourself up to it there's gonna be
opportunities for it to find you and for
you to interact and enjoy that feeling
you know it says i had intense sexual
trauma after my relationship with my ex
it's been over a year since i left him
now and i've finally recovered i'm
extremely proud of myself for that it
was one of the most difficult things to
bear through but i made it
yesterday was my birthday and late at
night i got sad thinking about him and
missing our relationship
i feel ashamed that he was the last
person i thought of he hurt me so bad
and shouldn't deserve my thoughts of
affection
i thought i was past this state and me
missing him feels like a betrayal
towards the younger version of me she
who's completely destroyed and i swore
to never betray myself like that again
i feel like
healing from trauma isn't linear
and
you can never really
expect yourself to be past a certain
point
that's something i have to remind myself
of too and it's not easy
yeah healing doesn't happen in a
straight line and
sometimes you feel like you backtrack
but
it's
it's all part of the process and some
days are easier than others so you just
kind of have to
like let the emotions come and go
naturally
um
but also
i mean whoever that was i'm so proud of
you for like
making the effort to heal and for going
through that and
yeah bearing with it for however long it
takes
[Music]
after riding mine
um i feel good
i
mine was pretty light-hearted um and i
like
that i got to participate so i feel good
all right that's it for today's episode
thank you for watching i love you all
and i'll see you next week
[Music]